[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The Google Brain
team's long-term goal
is to create more intelligent
software and systems
that improve people's
lives, which they pursue
through both pure and
applied research in a variety
of different domains.
On "The Developer Show,"
we've shared a bunch of links
to their work over
the last year.
But there's so much more.
Take a look at this post
linked in the description
below for a review
of the progress
the team has made in
2016 and some of what
may be in store for 2017.
The Chrome Media
Team has created
Draco, an open-source
compression library
to improve the storage and
transmission of 3D graphics.
With it, applications
using 3D graphics
can be significantly
smaller without compromising
visual fidelity.
For examples and a
link to the GitHub,
head on over to the post.
We recently simplified
and improved the Merchant
experience for those
of you who have
paid apps, in-app
purchases, or subscriptions.
These include moving Order
Management to the Google Play
Developer Console, adding
some improved features,
and making Payments Settings
accessible from the Developer
Console in addition to
payments.google.com.
For all of the details,
check out the post.
Google Cloud Key
Management Service
is now available in beta
in select countries.
With Cloud KMS, you can manage
symmetric encryption keys
in a cloud-hosted
solution, whether they're
used to protect data stored
in GCP or another environment.
For more on how this fits
into the Google Cloud Platform
encryption continuum and
links to get started,
check out the post.
If you're in San Francisco next
month for the RSA conference,
stop by our SF office for a
series of 20 security talks
just up the street
from the conference.
The schedule of
talks is on the post.
And now for some API updates.
We recently introduced
Business Location Insights
into Google My Business
API to make it easier
for you to programmatically
access location
insights such as total number
of searches, views, and actions
that let you track and
analyze where and how people
are finding your
business on Google.
We've made the
coursework endpoints
in the Classroom API more robust
with additional management
capabilities, enabling your
app to create and update
questions, modify and
delete coursework, and add
Drive items and YouTube videos
to coursework and student
submissions.
For more details on what you
can build with coursework,
head on over to the post
for a cool video and links.
Oh, and for you AdWords
users, remember to transition
to expanded text ads
before January 31st, 2017.
You may want to
start with the best
practices and other docs linked
on the post in the description
below.
Don't forget to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, thanks for watching this
episode of "The Developer
Show."
For some more of
our great episodes,
check them out right here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]